قبل اليوم النطق بالحكم كنت متواجد مع
زملائي في
في المنطقه الخضراء احنا طبعا يعني خلونا
باحد بالقصر الرئيسي يعني قصر الجمهوري
هناك
يعني المنام السكن
بيوم التقينا التقينا بقاعه المحكمه انا
وزملائي كان الجو مشحون يعني بوضع غير
اعتيادي فكان يجلس على كرسي
واحنا نفس الكراسي اللي جالسين على طاوله
مستطيله انا وزملائي انا كنت يعني قريب
منه على يساره
يعني كالعاده بجلوسنا او على يمينه فكان
يعني
يعني ماخذ حاله استرخاء الكرسي وكان يعني
يدفع نفسه الى الوراء والى الامام على
الكرسي ففجاه سقط الرئيس
نادى علي ابني هايفه من جيت اني احمل كان
يعني وزنا ثقيل يعني وزنه ثقيل
يتعاونوني زملائي
كان يتصور انه الحاله متعمده فنبهنا
الحاله حاله سقوطها انه متقصدين الامريكان
انه جابوها الكرسي حتى يصير يحصل لي اللي
يحصل اكدناه لانه هاي الكراسي اعتقد يعني
منشاه صيني وهي اثناء الحركه يعني يصير
بها يعني تحمى وصير بهاللي صار
فبعد ان غيروا الكرسي ماله وانتهى اللقاء
مدتها ثمان ساعات الا ربع كان يعني الجو
مشحون جدا شخصيا ما كان متوتر بس كان
حاسين احنا يعني لقاء الوداع هذا يعني
عارفين انه القرار الامور بدها تتجه بهذا
الاتجاه
نعم
يعني عاده اللقاءات يقسمها يعني يقسمها
بالمنتصف يعني
والنص الاخر نبقى يعني هيك هو يطلب من
المحامين من الزملائي
الاخيره كنت اتوقع يعني احنا كنا كنا
نتوقع انه اللقاء الاخير هذا
فاثناء التوديع
زملائي خرجوا بقينا انا واياه واقفين
فكانت يعني عيوني بعيونها يعني
نظر يعني متقابل
ونظرته الي كانت يعني نظره مليئه يعني
الروح الابويه وهو يودع يعني ابناء شعبه
وانا اكون جزء من عندهم وانا نفس الحاله
قاعدي يبقى هو رئيسي رئيس العراق
فكنت بذيك اللحظه يعني وصلت الى مرحله كنت
اريد يعني اريد الجانب الامريكي ياخذه
لانه ما اريد اضعف امامه
فبعد ان اخذوه الجانب الامريكي وقبل يعني
وصول للباب بعد ان عبر الباب اجهزه بصوت
عالي جدا بالبكاء وهذا اللي كنت دائما اني
ما اريده يحصل لكن الامور خرجت عن السيطره
والى ان يعني اجا الضابطه الامريكي وحاول
يعني اتك عليه ما كنت اريد انه اتك عليه
لانه هو سبب كل مصائب العراق
ناديت على زملائي واجوا زملائي وطلعنا من
القاعه